so what i have here
is something from apparently uh the
theater community
in atlanta and here dear white american
theater
we come together as a community of black
indigenous and people of color
so by poc what's the new acronyms the
new acronym
uh theater makers in the legacy of
august wilson's the ground on which i
stand to let you know exactly
what the gra what ground we stand on in
the wake of the nation's civic unrest
um so this goes on to say
so there is no entity called white
american theater they are addressing
everyone who is white who is in american
theater is that the idea
yes i believe so uh you know i i can't
imagine that there would be anything
called white american theater
um that would be extraordinarily archaic
and
likely offensive and so in some sense
this is the description of a boogeyman
and the boogeyman is one in which um
theater has been oppressing black people
in some
transparent way on every
stage at all times and this is the claim
that it has been seen which is
effectively very close to an empirical
claim
right this is not an allegation this is
a description it's an eyewitness account
of something
that can't possibly be happening but
anyway
my point here isn't about theater and
it's not about atlanta
it's about the fact that you wouldn't
know this was happening
except that if you tune in to this
little world of atlanta theater you
discover oh my goodness the coup
is happening right and well we heard
from a lot of people in theater after
evergreen blew up
you know we your inbox blew up thousands
and thousands of emails and i
went through many of them and there were
a tremendous number of people
writing in from theater now what are the
chances that people who go into theater
are particularly racist or bigoted
or unwilling to investigate other
narratives about what might be going on
right no
like this is what art is this is what
art is for is
precisely about engaging with
different perspectives different ways of
living different historical periods
different places
different ideologies different
demographics all of this this is what we
need narrative for and theater is a
particularly
wonderful way of engaging it i mean you
and i both enjoy live theater quite a
lot we've been going
to we've taken our children to live
theater multiple times a year for years
now
and um and we've been hearing a little
bit from people we actually know
in a couple of these theater companies
but much more so
from a number of anonymous well people
who we don't know but who
um came to us with their stories theater
troops
seem particularly prone to prostrate
themselves before this ridiculous
false set of accusations and gods
when they are actually doing some of the
most forward thinking
um god i can't use the word anti-racist
anymore but like actually
anti-racist narrative work and therefore
the presentation of narrative work is
one of the places that we work
out the difficult nuances that's the
whole point of the exercise
and so to have something behind the
scenes taking place that erases all
nuance and creates totally phony
narratives right is toxic and we've seen
this week a number of cases in which
you know in some uh animated series some
white actor was voicing a character of
color and they've now
stepped down so in those cases we could
say whatever these are
celebrities they'll you know they've got
plenty of resources
maybe it shouldn't have been a white
person along but my point is
this is now a threat the point is this
is a threat going forward right
every time you have a job opening you
have to bend over backwards
to make sure that the accusation that
you've done anything
um other than prioritize the voices of
people that you know
have demographic markers that you can
spot
you have to make every effort to do that
so the point is yes
this is a coup and some of the people
paying the price are celebrities and
maybe
that's not all that awful right i don't
like it but the point is
if you're a celebrity you've probably
got resources but this is going to this
is going to fall down on the heads
of thousands and thousands of people who
are depending on you know
theater is a difficult line of work and
if you are suddenly now unable to get a
job
because your demographic markers don't
slate you for one that's a disaster
furthermore it threatens all narrative
it threatens
all of our ability to hear stories that
don't sound like what we expect
the idea i mean this isn't i don't have
an example from this week
but over the last few years we've heard
these
many stories of okay so i think it was
janine cummings is her name who wrote
american dirt
she has maybe a puerto rican grandmother
i may be getting some of the
descriptions wrong i didn't know we were
going to be talking about this
but her book tour was canceled her book
almost canceled
on the basis that how dare she write a
book
about a middle-class mexican woman
and her son running from the narcos
through mexico and ultimately escaping
to the u.s
because she is not herself
mexican-american nor has she herself
escaped from the narcos
um she had no right to write this um
they you know
that publisher was obliged apparently
to find instead someone who wished to
write a novel
um who already lived that life well this
is
misunderstanding you know everything but
you know what is fiction
for one thing but also if we are
really in this landscape where you
cannot write
from the perspective of someone else we
are being asked to forgo
all that is best about humanity we we i
i can
i cannot am i i am not allowed to
imagine myself
into your brain because let's see you're
male
and you're jewish and you know so many
other things that
make you different for me if we take
that to its most obvious extreme
none of us can possibly imagine the
experience of anyone else and therefore
we are forbidden from writing fiction
full stop it is the it is the death of
fiction is the death of narrative we can
only write
from and this is what they say with
regard to lived experience you know the
the best form of knowledge the only
legitimate form of knowledge i've even
heard
is lived experience and that's that's
the end of science
that's the end of hypothetical
deductionism that's the end of analysis
but it's also we've said that many times
it's also the end of fiction and
narrative
it's just we're just doomed across the
board it's the end of empathy
um and i would point out uh
example that just pops to mind and i if
i'd known we were headed here i would
have looked up the actor's name but
the movie uh life is beautiful i think
was its name
about a jewish father
who tries to make life for his son
bearable
in uh i believe it's auschwitz
and the actor who plays the main role
was
roberto benini yeah that's right um so
you it's hard for me even to imagine an
outcry about the fact that you know this
this heartbreaking story acted so
beautifully by this actor
that he didn't happen to be jewish is
irrelevant and maybe it's even a triumph
in some sense because
he you know he really evokes it and so
isn't this what we want isn't isn't this
exactly what we want for other people to
be able to understand
not only our joys but our pain this this
is what we are looking for this is the
connection that is what is human yep
and we are being told how dare you try
to understand me you cannot
you shall not you will not we will
threaten you
yeah until you fall into line with all
of these other things but do not
dare try to imagine that you can report
on what it is
to be me okay now add a dash of orwell
okay uh hey zach can you bring up the uh
the other
town hall for racial reckoning our
community is experiencing a reckoning
the global effects of the pandemic and
now the civil unrest in our communities
are highlighting the disparities between
white lives
and the lives of people of color
especially black people a seismic
shifting of the status quo is
threatening to rock the foundation upon
which so many theaters in this community
have built their legacies
when we are able to make theater again
we cannot return to quote business as
usual
and quote we cannot return to theater
companies that will not acknowledge and
respect the voices of the bipod
community
in an effort to make sure those voices
are heard the coalition for racial
equity
in atlanta theater creat an inclusion
diversity equity in the arts atlanta
idea atlanta have partnered to host a
three-night virtual town hall
okay so can you scroll up
okay you can sign up to attend here's a
list of the theaters that
are uh going to participate
um so i get go down
and uh can you click rules of engagement
yeah on the left no other one left that
was press release
there we go rules of engagement now the
basic idea and these rules of engagement
i will spare you all of the detail but
the basic rules are
certain people are empowered to speak
about the horrors in the atlanta theater
community
scrub just a little bit zach stop we ask
that all speakers speak
only to their own personal experience it
may cause further trauma to speak of
someone else's experience if they are
not yet ready
the administrators are told it is they
will not be given an opportunity
to speak and they are instructed
that they must maintain they must have
their cameras
on at all times okay
they are not allowed to turn off their
cameras so they are going to sit and
they are going to listen
to uh stories of lived experience they
will not be empowered to respond in any
way and they must do so with the cameras
on so that their expressions
will be constantly available uh for all
who attend as witnesses
a witness is a bipark or alley theater
make or ally
sorry theater maker who wishes to be
present support we ask that you remain
respectful throughout the evening fair
enough
please try and limit extraneous movement
during the process
eg driving or washing driving or washing
dishes
okay can you scroll up and find the uh
where cameras will be on
stop dude there it is at the bottom
uh the very bottom okay no that's all
attendees
there's also the administrators are
being specifically instructed that they
must
have their cameras on at all time and i
can't i don't see where it is but
anyway um this is absolutely orwellian
it is a twist on struggle sessions it is
struggle sessions in
theater all of the uh dangers that you
and i were just talking about
flow from this rather directly but again
the point really isn't about theater
the point is we've seen this up close
and personal
in colleges and universities we've seen
it in schools of ed
we've seen it in uh in journalism and it
is spreading at a rapid rate we're
seeing
the democratic party play ball with this
thing at the highest
possible levels and
what is the natural remedy so my point
would be look
you've got natural remedies this is
completely insane people are being
fired for things that they never did
they're being fired for completely
symbolic reasons
that's not actually legally acceptable
right but you would have to go to a
court to establish that you had been
harmed
this is also going to be in every single
court right
so it is getting harder to imagine that
a
uh a white plaintiff could prevail in
such a case
if they you know if the juries and
judges are
sensitive to the fact that they may be
next to be portrayed
as uh somehow white supremacist
so this is a this is an orwellian
nightmare all of the natural remedies
if the court fails what's supposed to
protect you well journalism
the fact of the court having failed
might be reported and people might say
oh my goodness what's going on in the
court system how did it get so broken
well that's going to be gone too there's
no remedy left
and that is a truly frightening fact
we are watching a horizontal revolution
and frankly
i don't know where it isn't